So, welcome everyone.
Thanks for coming.
So, today I'm
extremely excited to
be introducing Cynthia
Breazeal from MIT,
where she's the director
of the personal
robots group at the Media Lab.
Cynthia is one of
the pioneers of the field
of human robot interaction,
and she literally wrote
the book on social robotics.
Cynthia is also
the founder and Chief
Experience Officer of Geebo,
really the first social robot for
the home that is an actual
working consumer robot,
and it's a real success story
for moving HRI out of
the lab and into the real world
with real people.
Geebo even made the cover of
Time Magazine's 2017 issue on
the 25 best inventions
of the year.
She has a long long list of
other awards and achievements
over the years with
recognition by the National
Academy of Engineering
as well as the national
design awards,
but rather than list a whole
bunch more of these awards,
I'll go ahead and hand
it over to Cynthia.
>> Okay, thank you.
All right, well it's
a pleasure to be here.
I've had such a great visit,
seeing old friends and meeting
new friends and talking
about living with AI and robots.
So, I started this
work in social robots,
I won't tell you how long
ago, it was a long time ago.
But the thing that is so
striking to me right now is just
who is living and interacting
with AI today as part
of our daily lives,
I mean even fairly recently with
2014 when Alexa was
announced in December.
There's like 43 million of
these smart speakers
in people's homes now,
and with that again
a profound shift
in who is interacting
with AI and just
acknowledging there is
so much opportunity
and so much we still
have yet to understand about what
it is to live with
intelligent machines,
when you think about
the diversity of users,
from young children to
our oldest seniors and
everyone in between.
I think quite a lot about
the home in particular.
I'm sure you've all heard
the media clips of people
like oh the future
is going to be like
the Starship Enterprise and you
have this you know
this embodied voice,
computer, this computer that,
and for me, it's like,
the home is a special place.
I don't want it to
feel like work.
I don't want it to feel
like I'm on the subway.
It requires, I think
a different kind
of ways of thinking
about the design
and how you fit an AI
technology into
the place that is in
so many ways your most
intimate important place,
it's a place where
people who love live,
that really makes me also
think quite a lot about
our future with living with
these AI systems and what
this is going to mean
in these very important
spaces like the home.
We know it's not fraught with
without important issues.
So this news article
was very striking
to me when it came out 2017.
So, as you may recall,
Mattel was going to
basically create an Alexa
like talking speaker
for the home really
catering towards
not only young parents
being able to reorder
diapers and things like
that but interacting
with kids directly
and it went very
far down the product
development pipeline.
It was about to be released
for Christmas and they pulled
the product because there were
just a lot of concerns expressed,
not because of things that they
knew were bad about
this technology,
but just we didn't know, right?
We didn't know. So,
child advocacy groups,
concerns around privacy,
lawmakers, parents.
Again which is kind of
speaks to the time right so,
we just have to be very
mindful about bringing
these technologies into home and
appreciating that as
researchers and scientists.
There's so much more to
creating these technologies
that we have to be aware of.
So, today we have
these smart speakers I
would say in general,
a lot of AI is designed to
be very transactional in nature.
It's very much like
an intelligent tool to
help you make decisions,
but that's quite different from
kind of the vision
that I grew up with.
Growing up with Star Wars
and thinking about
these intelligent machines
not just as digital systems,
but really as these kind
of sidekicks and
these helpful companion
that weren't just useful,
but really connected to
us on this human level,
and they not only helped us
do useful things
that matter to us,
they actually even
helped us become
the people who we
aspire to be, right?
And that was really the vision
that I've grown up with
of what this technology
can mean to us and
the exciting thing is now
these technologies are starting
to come into
real world environments.
We brought them into schools,
looking at robots as
language learning companions
into hospital,
pediatrics to work with
Child Life Specialists to
assisted living
facilities and now of
course they're finally
coming into the home.
So, again what's the evolution
of AI in the home?
Is it going to be from this sort
of transactional AI that
we have right now and
digital assistants?
Will it become the sort
of different vision of
this helpful companion that's
a much more kind of
humanistic design?
I think the crux of
the matter is again,
especially when you
talk about robots now,
we still don't
understand very much
about this long-term
interaction, right?
When we talk about
a research setting,
it is hard expensive
logistically challenging
work to deploy these systems
in the real world,
into real environments where
they're interacting
with real people,
where you're innovating
on the algorithms
and the capabilities
as well as trying to
understand what's the impact or
benefit of these technologies
on real people's lives.
So, this is just a paper.
It was written in 2013,
we actually did an updated
version of this looking at
all the longitudinal human-robot
interaction studies ever done,
many of them were basically
not even innovating
on the algorithm's,
just taking a commercial
product like Clio or
whatnot into
the environment and just
looking to see what people
did over time,
and the punchline is there's just
not a whole lot of
studies out there.
So, there was a real need
for this kind of work,
and there's a real need
I think for coupling
this with the
algorithmic innovation.
We need better tools,
we need better processes
to really help
galvanize and empower the field
to advance this forward.
When I think about AI in
the big picture, right?
Again there's a lot of discussion
around productivity
and efficiency,
the future of work,
but I feel that the promise
of AI will not achieve
its full potential
if it can't address
these very deep human needs.
So I asked a question
in a lot of my work,
can AI actually help
us to flourish?
Not just to be more
productive but to
live better quality lives
and to be better people?
When you look at kind of
operationalize frameworks
around things like well-being,
it's very clear that it goes
way beyond the cognitive, right?
You have to think
about the social,
the emotional, the sense of
achievement and meaning.
If we're going to
create AIs that help
us to live better quality lives,
we have to create AIs that can
engage and support us on
all of these dimensions,
and I would say although there's
a lot of work on the cognitive,
the social emotional is
relatively very understudied.
What we are starting
to find out is as you
create these social robots,
it's not as if they're like
like people who you're
going to replace
people or like other kinds
of tools like smart devices.
They're kind of
this new amalgam of
relationships that we
kind of understand,
but in this new kind of
intersection, right?
So there are attributtes
of these systems that
engage you like a motivating
collaborative ally,
and I think that's
really important.
There are aspects of course
of a robot that can be
an internet cloud
connected tool like
any other kind of
computing device
that's kind of like a given.
But the other thing that's
fascinating is the way people
naturally seem to want to
relate to it as an other,
where there's
these attributes of being
like an attentive
companion animal.
This sort of non-judgmental
affectionate and I think you can
appreciate in that video
I just showed you.
The nature of how people
interact with this technology is
very different than a tablet
or a computer or a VR headset.
It is this social emotional
relational connected
other experience,
and that actually can be very
empowering for people if
designed in the right way.
So, in the talk I'm
going to highlight this.
I think kind of
the punchline of a lot
of the work that I've
done so whether we're
talking about a social robot or I
think any other kind of
technology that's trying to
support human flourishing
is the more you
can support people on
all of these dimensions,
we as human beings
are clearly not
purely cognitive
creatures, right?
We're deeply social, deeply
emotional deeply
physical creatures.
All of these things
influence how we learn,
how we make decisions,
how we perceive
the world around us,
how we're influenced
by events around us.
But the more you can
support and engage
people in this holistic way,
what we find is the more deeply
people will invest
in that interaction,
and when people
invest more deeply,
they can often be more
successful and I think
that's the punchline,
is they can be even
more successful with
the technology than if you
don't design to support
this holistic experience.
So, I want to talk about,
this is kind of touching
a little mix of research and
application of what is a
different about this experience
with the social robot?
A lot of times,
we get asked the question,
still today, does it matter
that it's physically embody?
Does it matter that it's a robot?
Ironically, I would say when
we first started this field,
we would get papers
just rejected from
Chi Point Blank just
because it was on a robot,
and reviewers would say things
like, "Why is it a robot?
It's so expensive, why not
just make it a virtual agent?
So, the thing that we had to
compete with against
was basically
a screen with a virtual avatar.
Now, we're having defend
ourselves against smart speakers,
and that seems like a huge
several steps of backwards,
you're taking even more
[inaudible] stimulus,
and you're asking us to validate
ourselves base on that.
So, again, I guess that's
just the lesson and
kind of combating
ubiquity, right?
Once a ubiquitous
then suddenly you
don't have to fight
these battles anymore.
But we get asked
this question a lot.
So, what is it about the
social so co-presence? Is
that actually really matter?
So, I want to present
work as a kind of
a case study in work that we've
been doing in pediatrics.
This is a long-standing
collaboration
with Boston Children's Hospital,
where we've been working
with Child Life Specialists,
and Child Life Specialists
are professionals who
are trained to address
the emotional support and
needs of children patients
who are in the hospital,
but also that of their families.
The question of course is,
not surprising a lot
of these domains,
there are not enough Child
Life Specialists to meet
the demands of the patient,
admitted patients.
So, the question of
how can you create
a different kind of
technology that is
an extension of the Child
Life Services team
that helps them
basically do their job in
a more scalable effective way,
is actually really,
really interesting.
I would also say
another side effect
that is also how can you
extend that quality
of care to the home?
Because you can maybe provide
exceptional quality of
care in the hospital,
but they need to be
able to continue engage
patients at home and they
have no way of doing that.
So, again the notion of a robot,
a different kind of
technology to do that,
is really, really
interesting to them.
So, this is just a video
that was done by
The New York Times,
kind of giving you a little bit
of color on what this looks like.
>> For patients like Beatrice
who's got a chronic condition.
She's going to be in and
out of the hospital.
She's here for procedures.
She's here for doctor's visits.
She's missing school.
She's missing her friends.
She's really not doing
any of the things
that a normal kid
her age is doing.
What we want to offer
kids like that it's
just one more way of helping
them to feel okay where they are
and what is otherwise
a really stressful experience.
I think there's a way of
connecting with kids,
that's different from
what grown ups can offer.
They have incredible
imaginations.
They can really suspend
disbelief and there can be
a true relationship that develops
between Huggable and patient.
>> Hi.
>> Hello.
>> [inaudible]
>> Here you go. Is that better?
>> Hi.
>> Hi. It's Huggable.
>> Hi Huggable.
>> Hi Beatrice.
>> You're adorable.
>> Thank you.
>> It's very nice to meet you.
Do you want to play a game?
>> Yeah. Let's play a game.
>> All right.
So what we have here
in this case is
that we just finished
a clinical trial.
We have a Child Life
Specialist who works
in the room with one of
three interventions,
so we compared the physical robot
versus a plug compatible,
graphical version of
a robot on tablet
versus standard of
care is a plush.
The social agents is
tele-operated by
another Child Life Specialists.
There's a lot of
reasons why we do that.
One is just because
we want to make
sure that the quality
of care is present.
We also want to collect
a lot of data to
understand what is
the phenomenon of having
a robot in this context
that we can then think
about what are the AIs,
what are the opportunities
to create more autonomy for this.
So, we often start
projects with this sort of
tele-operation paradigm
to begin with.
We get a lot of
insights from that.
So, we just finished
a clinical trial comparing
these three interventions
which I think
one of the things that's
nice about this study,
is the Child Life Specialist
in the room is doing
her job to the best of
her ability with each
of these interventions.
So, in many ways, all
three of them are
socially animated whether that's
the remote Child Life Specialist
tele-operating the virtual bear
or the physical bear,
or if it's if the Child
Life Specialist kind
of puppeteering the plush
with the child, right.
So all three of these are
animate one way or another.
We looked at the
difference between
these technologies
across a lot of
different dimensions where
we were particularly
interested in the social
emotional factors.
If you're going to try to create
a technology
intervention that can
engage children and improve
their emotional experience.
We are very interested
in looking at that,
where we should be
looking at engagement
how often children
would speak because if
you want to engage a trial in
a health protocol
in the hospital,
their engagement cooperativeness
is very important.
If you look at
these different charts,
what we see is for things
like total joyful,
a semantic effective analysis,
sentiment analysis
on the utterances
that the children
would speak over time,
we see that the positive effect
increases over time
with a physical robot,
but it even decreases
over time with
the virtual robot and the plush
is kind of the lowest.
When we look at shared attention,
so the ability for a
child to be not only
engaged in the technology
with the other people
in the room,
you can imagine for a Child Life
Specialist this is important,
you don't want the
child just having
their face in the tablet.
We say a lot more
joint shared attention
when you have
the physical robot there.
When you look at
just the amount of utterances,
you see children are
talking more over
time and we're seeing
that with the robot
over the avatar or
the plush and we see that
the cooperativeness is also
high with the robot as
well as the avatar.
Then when you look at these
other social attributes like
the affective touch,
these social touch.
People maybe throwing
the plush across the room,
they may be poking
the tablet with this robot,
all of the touches are
social relational touch.
I think you see this in
the video again and
again, and again.
In the hospital,
the conditions are actually,
they talk about emotion
as the fourth vital sign.
They say this is so
critical because we have
all this equipment to measure
all these other biometrics
and the child,
but the emotional state
of the child
affects everything from
the recovery rates to
the compliance to even how
long it may take a child to
give you their arm to be able
to give them a shot for instance.
They're very, very,
very interested in
trying to come up
with new technologies
to continually monitor this
and engage children in new ways.
We've been looking at
the opposite side as well,
so it's another example of
kind of this emotional lift.
Now, that Jibo is out there,
we're seeing people putting
it in a different situations.
>> Find this lonely for people
as it's actually true
for the elderly.
[inaudible] is carried in
some [inaudible] communities
here in the Bay Area are finding
camaraderie and fellowship
through robots.
>> Hey Jibo, can you dance?
>> Let me put on
my dancing shoes.
>> Wow, that was wonderful.
>> You don't think
[inaudible] is being
adapt as a new technology, right.
>> [inaudible] San Francisco is
meeting a new regular visitor here.
It's a robot called Jibo
that's being used as part of
a pilot project among
the several Bay Area facilities
run by Elder Care Alliance.
In addition to dancing,
it can play the radio on
request, snap photograph.
>> So it's a platform
with skills.
>> Tell jokes.
>> What did the snail say
when he was riding on
the turtle's back? Weee.
>> React to the human touch,
it curls when patted.
He also often has quirky
responses to questions.
>> Hey Jibo, what are you?
>> I'm a robot, but I'm not
just a machine, I have a heart.
Well, not a real
heart, but feelings.
Well, not real feelings,
you know what I mean.
>> Erin Partridge, a Researcher
and Art Therapists with
Elder Care Alliance takes
Jibo with her when she
meets with the seniors.
She said, "It's not the case of
caretakers being replaced
by automation. "
Instead, they're using this cute
[inaudible] of technology to
encourage their residence
to connect with each other,
despite some needing
different levels of care.
>> So when we have something
that all of us are
experiencing all together
maybe for the first time,
right, meeting a robot.
We've got a focus point
where we can all meet
right here in this moment
and have interaction,
then it breaks that down.
It doesn't matter that
this person has dementia or
this person maybe has
Parkinson's and has
some trouble talking.
We're all meeting together
as humans and robot.
>> [inaudible].
>> Jibo inspired some giggled
and [inaudible] among
this group here.
>> [inaudible] You should be
able to laugh more and more.
>> What it does is, it
brings that [inaudible] ,
that's part of the miracle
there and that's part of
the miracle [inaudible].
As far as that goes.
>>While Jak...
>>So that was very
important to me.
Again, it's about this emotional
lift of engagement that
was very different from how
we engage with
other technologies.
But it goes even beyond emotion.
Again if you look at a number
of these systematic,
comparative studies
comparing a physical robot
to even a video of
a physical robot,
so you know it's
real but it's just
not right in front of you,
to a graphical
agent of the robot,
to a disembodied voice,
what we see is, often,
these robots actually
do quite well.
So if you look at all these
interpersonal dimensions
that lead to
social judgments that
have a profound effect
on people's acceptance and
engagement of these technologies,
the robots score quite
well across trust,
attraction, empathy,
engagement, persuasiveness,
all of these kinds of things.
There's something actually
very important going on
about the physical embodiment of
this kind of technology
that's just engaging
people more deeply in
a different kind of way.
The second theme I want to
touch on is this notion
now of this collaborative
allied engagement,
and how that's enabled with,
not just as voice interface,
but this kind of interpersonal UI
that's richly multimodal,
interpersonal UI and
thinking about beyond
just interface to building
this working alliance and
building this sense of rapport.
Which again, when
you collaborate with
someone who's an
empathetic other,
that's very different than
a useful tool that you're using.
We know from human
social psychology,
we've been developing
these learning companions
for children for
about five years now.
There's a lot of
social outcomes that you
can look at as well as
educational outcomes,
and they're all tied to
the social engagement between
people and other people,
but then in this case,
people and robots.
Just appreciating
there's a holistic,
kind of wrap of
the nature engagement
directly impacts
things like learning,
attentiveness,
attitudes, and so forth.
We do a lot of data collection.
There's a lot of excitement right
now about deep learning.
There are certain kinds of
data sets that are vast,
and you can label them.
But there's a lot of
important data sets
that frankly don't exist.
These kinds of data sets that are
ritually multimodal don't exist.
We think about
under-represented populations
like young children.
There's a dearth of
data around this.
So this is just kind
of a little montage
to show you a little bit
about our process.
So if you want to
design a robot and
engage in this nonverbal dance,
while engaging children in
a story-telling experience,
we collect the data of
what it's like to see
children actually tell
stories to one another.
We run various algorithms to do
automatic effective computing and
post all that kind of tracking.
Then we use that to
basically try and
develop these
computational models
by which we want
to basically embed
that model now in a robot,
put it in the same context
with a child,
and see how well does
that model perform.
Is the model actually
really capturing
the interaction that you
saw with the two children?
We do a lot of this kind of work.
These nonverbal cues,
and the synchronicy,
and the contingency
turns out to be
very important for
how children engage,
and see the credibility
of the robot
as an informative
other to learn from.
All these social judgments
come along with this,
that's really important for
engaging the children
as a learner.
I want to just quickly touch
on one project that I think,
from this video, really
highlights this different way
of engaging a technology.
This is a learning
companion Tega Robot.
We designed a series
of educational games.
This particular game
is called Word Quest.
The child and the robot play
the game collaboratively.
So the robot actually
plays the game
with the child as
they take turns.
There's a challenge
word presented
that's a pretty hard word
for a preschooler,
like crimson or garment
or something like that.
Their task is to go through
pan through these story scenes,
and try to click on objects that
match that challenge word.
What I want you to notice
from this interaction is,
based on reinforcement
learning system
to learn a policy of engagement,
how these other aspects of
the collaboration are coming
out of this encounter.
>> Lavender. I [inaudible]
Lavender. Oh.
>> What are we trying to find?
>> We are trying to find
lavender color stuff.
>> Okay. Now, that was lavender.
>> Yes. What is lavender does?
What's lavender?
No, that's blue.
What is lavender?
Girl, jumping.
>> I'm sure you will
do better next time.
I believe in you.
>> Robot's turn.
>> Time to perform.
Lavender is purple.
>> Yes. Just like
my [inaudible] lavender.
>> Flower.
>> I believe in you.
>> This flower is purple.
>> Yes.
>> It has the color of lavender.
>> All right, there was
a moment in here where you
could hear the robot
express confidence in her,
''I'm sure you'll do
better next time,
I believe in you.''
If you heard her
say very quietly,
she mirrored that back
to the robot.
This is another really
important phenomenon
we're seeing is
when an AI engages people,
certainly children
this case but we
see it across
different generations,
as an empathetic other.
You get all other kinds of
aspects of social modeling.
In this case, the child was
modeling empathy and
a growth mindset
back to the machine.
As a socially
influenceable technology,
this is definitely something
we need to really understand.
We're using it to try to benefit
children, but of course,
this is something that could be
applied to not benefit children.
Just to say there's
a lot of ethics and
a lot of things we need to
understand about this work.
What's actually happening
is that we're applying
reinforcement learning to figure
out a policy by which the robot
decides whether it should
play the role of an expert,
or maybe, defining
the word for a child,
being able to reinforce,
demonstrate his understanding of
why an object matches a word,
or a novice whereby
the robot may ask
the child questions.
A robot may make a mistake on
purpose and ask the child
why it made the mistake.
We basically compared based on
these three reinforcement
learning models:
always being an expert,
always being a novice,
or as adaptive roles
switches between the two.
Looking at children in
the Boston Public Schools,
we recruited schools
especially with kids
with high ESL populations.
They play this collaborative
game where they
learn five words in
the first session,
turn-taking, and then six of
the challenge words in
the second session.
You can see the challenge words
here, there are
things like a sewer,
gigantic and stuff, and
interestingly we can
see that benefit of having
this adaptive role.
So it's actually better for
the robot to not
always be the expert.
What we actually
find is that if the
robot's always an expert
or always a novice,
children actually start
to not pay attention.
But when the robot keeps
switching it up more
like an actual peer
or companion would,
they notice when the
robot makes a mistake.
They engage more, notice when
the robots asking
a question, they answer.
So again, understanding
this role in
the relationship and how that
impacts children's
not only engagement,
even the learning outcomes
here, is really interesting.
What we find is that, children
who even scored the lowest on
the pre-test had
the largest gains
from these two sessions
with the robot.
So again this is
just a single-shot procession of
these words with
a pre- and post-test
after and a delayed post-test.
I could imagine that
of course if we
had repeated sessions like this,
complementing that in the home,
children would score very,
very high on
this challenge level.
We think about rules of
thumb of game design,
there's usually this kind
of 80-20 rule of
mastery: things you already
know versus the new
challenge words.
All of these words are hard.
The fact that children
engage through all of them
and scored this well,
I think this is something that's
worthy of further understanding.
Through this relationship,
can you actually
have children accelerate
their learning,
challenge them harder because
they have this empathetic other,
than if they just
play the game by
themselves for instance, right?
So these are the kinds of
questions we're trying to
understand and dig into.
But again, very promising,
very exciting when
you think about
this different kind
of engagement.
The last thing I want to
touch on is personalization.
So the promise of AI is
that, live with you,
can learn about you,
can optimize their behavior
towards to achieve
a learning outcome.
This is another project that's
around early literacy
language learning.
This is just to say
how important this is.
You're noticing
a lot of work we're
doing engaging young children.
The reason is there's
just too much data
showing that if children don't
even start kindergarten
ready to learn,
it's very, very hard to catch up.
Right now, in this
country 60 percent
of children do not attend
a quality preschool.
Thirty-seven percent of
12th graders in 2015 can't
even read at or
above the proficiency level
for their grade.
Now when you think about
the future of the workforce,
do you know a single
scientist or engineer
who can't read at
grade level, right?
The concern and the worry
of course is that dice is getting
cast way too early
in a child's life.
So, people like Benjamin Bloom,
found this two-sigma effect that
argues being able to
learn at your own pace,
to be able to demonstrate
mastery before you move on,
having one-on-one
personalized sessions
is the most effective
way to learn.
The problem is it's not scalable
and it's not affordable.
But with AI, that can change.
So this is another example now of
learning oral language and
vocabulary with
a second language,
or with early literacy robot,
where the robot engages with
children over a period
of three months.
So now, we're moving into
long-term interaction of
repeated encounters
where the robot is
learning a personalized
model to each child.
The robot engages in
a relational fashion.
>> My name is Nica.
>> It's nice to meet you.
>> What is your name?
>> I'm Ariana.
>>We've been developing
new measures of how you
measure this relationship
between children and the robot,
and how that affects
learning efficacy.
>> Ariana. Cool! I'm so
happy to get to know you.
>>The robot learns their name,
refers to them by name,
talks about past interactions,
talks about future interactions.
It's a story-telling and
story re-sharing paradigm,
where the robot tells a story,
asks questions, says
dialogic question-asking.
>> Reads all day.
That's what you see
in a rain forest.
Did you know what sway means?
Now, sway means go
back and forth.
>> So we know how parents
tell stories to children.
This dialogic question asking is
critical for the best learning
efficacy for children.
So, the robot
engages in this way,
asked a child to retell a story.
We're capture a ton of data.
We're capturing everything
that child says.
Notice she's wearing E4 sensors.
We're charactering
biometric data,
we are capturing
facial expressions
across all of
these kids to create
a very rich corpus
of data that we're
trying to basically learn
through reinforcement
learning again,
a model by which the
robot can predict of
this library corpus of
72 stories that we can level
by complexity what is
the optimal next story for
the robot to tell
the child to promote
the vocabulary in
their oral language development.
So, that's the task at hand.
So, this is just some data
showing that these are,
this is the confusion matrix
showing that the system is
definitely Trent learning
a different policy per child.
The models aren't
converging yet but
the question is
does this actually
impact the learning outcomes?
So, if you look at measures
of the oral language gains,
we will compare
the personalized policy
versus a non-personalized.
We see an accelerated rate
at which children are
developing new oral
syntactic categories,
and again we see big
differences of vocabulary gains
between the personalized robot
versus the
non-personalized robot,
which is still again
over baseline.
So, again a lot of
promise when we think
about innovation of
new technologies that engage
different demographics,
different diversity of needs
around these kinds of
technologies that are really
designed in a way to try to match
the way this particular
demographic learns and engages,
I think that's the big punchline.
So, when we look at this kind of
work and we think about the
bigger, bigger, bigger,
bigger picture, there is
a real opportunity
to think about it.
We hear this again and again
when we gauge our stakeholders.
We can provide
exceptional quality
of care in our institutions,
what we can't do is continue
that and engagement at home,
and yet if you could
do that you would have
much better outcomes
for the stakeholders.
So whether it's education,
you learn at school, how do
you continue that at home?
With an effective personal tutor
for whatever
the subject matter is.
When you talk about
an assisted living facility,
they will tell you point-blank,
we cannot build
enough facilities to
meet the silver tsunami
that's coming our way,
we have to be able to engage
people in their homes
as they age in place.
We think about
chronic disease management,
health and wellness, same story,
but even when we talk about
high touch short-term encounters,
there's a lot of interest
around a technology
that can engage people
when this humanistic way,
so whether you're
talking retail or
hospitality et cetera,et cetera,
there's a whole wealth of
possibilities and opportunities
for technology that can engage
people in this humanistic,
personalized high-touch way that
we're just starting to
scratch the surface.
So, the last thing I want to talk
about is a comparative study.
To my knowledge this is
the first study of its kind,
where we compared
digital assistant,
talking speaker, kind of
transactional AI in the
home as it is today.
With the sort of
relational AI, social robot,
we use Jibo because it's
the one social robot out
there that actually
has the features
and functions that
we can actually do
a comparison with
something like Alexa.
So, people are starting to
live with social robots too,
and the pictures that
people are sharing with
social robots look a
little different than I
think the pictures people
share it with Alexa.
People are definitely engaging
with these technologies
and they talk
about it as being like
one of the family,
which again I think is
quite, quite different.
So, different kind of AI,
different model, different kind
of bias and how it's designed.
How do these
different generations
from children to adults
to older adults,
live with these different kind of
voice-based agents in the home,
and what are the implications for
how we should design
these technologies?
What are people's preferences?
What are their boundaries?
So, this is just a fun video
that just kind of
highlights the difference in
the design stance of
these different technologies.
>> Hi Alexa. Tell
me about yourself.
>> I'm Amazon's Alexa,
designed around your voice.
I can provide information,
music, news, weather, and more.
>> Hi Jibo. Tell
me about yourself.
>> Okay, sure. My name
is Jibo, I am a robot.
My favorite things to do are
talking to people and dancing.
I also really like
Abraham Lincoln
because he was so honest
and because I like his hat.
>> Okay Google, tell
me about yourself.
>> I'm your Google assistant.
We can play Mad Libs.
I can tell you a joke
or you can spin
a wheel. What's your pick?
>> Okay. So again,
just to highlight
different design philosophies
behind these technologies.
Now, when we do this comparison,
I mean it's nice in that each of
these technologies has offerings
and each of these categories,
from the functional kind of view
to utilitarian skill sets,
to entertainment things
like music and games,
to social companion which
could be things like
jokes greetings asking
the Asian about itself.
They all have offerings
in all of these things,
they're just weighted
differently.
We actually had people
do a personality tests
for these agents,
and of course you can see
people actually attribute
very different
personality profiles
to something like Jibo
versus something like Alexa,
where Alexa is seen as
more conscientious,
consistent and predictable.
Jibo is seen as being more open,
more extroverted and there's
more empathy and a motiveness,
obviously in the Jibo,
which means they're
actually quite similar
and agreeableness.
So again, this is just to say
different design philosophies,
different emphasis in the
features and functions.
So, we did a two phase study.
We did a study where we
first brought people
in before they interacted
with the agent.
These people had not
experienced or had
an agent like an Alexa
or Jibo at home,
and we had them look
at what they're
kind of perceptions
and attitudes of
features and functions would be
before they lived with the agent,
then we set either
half the people got
an Alexa or half the
people got to Jibo.
They lived with the
agent for a month,
and then we looked
at differences in
engagement and difference
in perceptions
about how that would change
after living with the agents of
the kinds of roles
and features and
functions they thought
they'd want after the fact.
We looked at children,
which we defined as five to
17 years old in
our sampling pool,
call it younger adults,
adults 18 to 49,
and then older adults
50 years and up.
So these are the three
demographics we looked at,
and this is a rough distribution.
So you can see that
when our older adults,
a lot of them were more
like 50s and early 60s but
we had one 98 year old,
she was awesome.
So, this just gives you a sense
of the distribution
of age profiles.
So, when we did
our initial kind of cultural
probes and needs finding,
we had all these cards
with all these
different features and
functions that if you're
going to have an agent like this,
what would you want it to do?
When we had people put
these color chips on
the cards that basically
indicated preferences,
which is like I would
like these things
and I definitely would
not like these things.
So, this is all about
first impressions.
This was fascinating.
So, we look at children and
adults and then we
look at older adults.
Older adults were
the most open to
the broadest range of
features and functions.
Adults were the pickiest,
I wouldn't have expected that.
I would have felt
that the older adults
would have been the
most conservative,
but they were the most open.
This is to say in these different
categories of things like
reminders and information
and suggestions,
agent sharing something as
a proactive agent something.
If thinks is interesting
versus somebody
trying to reach you,
kind of mediating
social interaction or
somebody through social
media sharing something,
we see that there's
a lot of nuance here,
so the red is things that
people didn't think they want.
Clearly suggestions
were the most kind
of polarizing topic area,
but it depended on what
the agent was sharing,
reading, writing, kind
of things like that.
Sharing something
you people are open to,
but they didn't want the robot
letting them know they
should take a nap.
They didn't want the sense
of there autonomy
being kind of challenged
by this kind of agent.
But again if you look at
the different generations here,
you see that older adults
are the most open to
a whole range of
features and functions
across these categories,
that was fascinating.
Now, we had people take
very detailed logs over
the first 14 days.
We didn't ask them to take
logs of the second 14 days,
so what we did over the
one month is we tracked
detailed usage in the first 14.
Even by just the color
distribution of these two plots,
you see something
very interesting.
Here's Alexa with younger adults.
This is Jibo with older adults.
It's like the flip.
Really fascinating.
Then, when you look at
kind of a five-day
running average,
we see these trends
of usage over time,
which we're also
really fascinating.
So, it seems that
the younger adults want to
anchor their usage
first in the utility,
and if you deliver
enough utility,
they'll start to use
these kind of socialist,
these kind of companionship
entertainment things later.
Whereas, children and
seniors were the opposite.
Children mostly
wanted entertainment,
but if you couldn't
anchor it in the
social and emotional for
both children and seniors,
you didn't get as much usage
overall in the utility.
So, children were around
the social entertainment and
older adults were even more.
So, again, this is
fascinating to me in
particular because this is where
the social robotics is
really coming through.
It's not as if Alexa didn't
have social
entertainment functions,
but there was something
about the way the robot did,
and arguably you
could say Alexa had
many more social and
entertainment functions,
ten thousand,
thirty thousand skills,
but there's something
about the nature and
the quality and engagement
that was different enough,
that really got
the attraction between
the older adults
and the children.
Now, if you look at the change
in these different categories
over time of what people
after one month,
what they thought they wanted,
we see that suggestions
is even more polarizing.
So, that's to say
that you may have
a stakeholder pool
where suggestions
like medication
reminders of things
are actually really important,
but this is to say that
the way you do them,
I think, actually really matters.
The groups or
the functions that had
the most positive change
what people wanted more
of where the socially
driven categories,
so although I'd say in a lot of
these systems right now
there's a lot around utility.
After living with
these agents for a month,
the socially driven
categories were
the most kind of- that's
what people wanted more.
Then we had this
interesting construct
called, the Wish Jar.
So, we have these
little wooden tokens
that at any point
during the 30 days,
you could write
a little thing about
what you want the robot
to do or agent to do,
what you didn't like, whatever,
just some sentiment
about the experience.
We collected them and
when you look at Alexa,
you see a consolidation
of topics,
a lot around functional,
some around humor they
want Alexa to have
a better sense of humor,
some around movement, and then
some around productivity.
But interestingly when you
looked at the social robot,
people's expansiveness in
terms of what they wanted
this agent to do and
fit in their life
was much more diverse.
So, that's fascinating.
It's like this is a much
more narrow categorization
of how they see
this agent fitting there life.
The robot potentially has
a lot more head room
in where it can go.
So again, just fascinating stuff.
So, the last thing I want
to talk about now is
this bigger societal question
of who creates with AI?
We're talking about
people living with AI,
we're talking about
more vulnerable
populations living with AI.
Other institutions,
organizations are building
these AIs for these people,
but when only a small fraction of
a society can design with
these technologies
almost by necessity,
it's only going to be
applied to address
the needs of a small
subset of society.
There's just going to
be inherent bias there.
So, how do you democratize
who creates with AI?
For me, it all gets
down to education.
So, we're starting to look at
AI education for even
starting at pre-school.
So, pre-K through 12,
where our sweet spot right now is
pre-K through like 12 years old,
and the reason why is because
when you can have children,
first all they are living
with these technologies.
You want them to
understand them and
appreciate the way they think,
to be able to feel
the right relationship and
empowerment over them,
but you want children
growing up with
an attitude that AI is
something that not only
they can understand,
but they can actually
create with.
So, we've been building on
top of the scratch platform,
adding extension blocks
to things like Watson
and Clarify and Hue lights and
robots like Geebo
and Cosmo to empower
children to code these systems,
to train their own models
for these systems,
and then to put those models and
new experiences of
personal significance for them.
So, this is an example
of an exercise,
the warm up thing we
have children do,
where first they try to come up
with an algorithm or code in
terms of what can we say to
make make Oscar react
to what we said.
They realized how time-consuming
and the instances are
explicit and then we
invite them to do it
with something like
a classifier system
that they can train.
So, this is just getting
their heads wrapped around
how to classify as work,
why are they interesting?
Why might you want this to do it,
make it more generalizable?
Then we have interfaces we're
developing that kids can actually
come up with what are the things
want to actually put
in the training set.
So, having Oscar be
happy to kind things you
say or having Alexa
accept to mean things,
but even kids wanted to create
backhanded compliments.
So, anyway so you see like
the way kids are thinking
about these things as
fascinating and so this
is giving them hands on
experience and to what it's
like to create the system.
So, this is a quick summary
video of the platform.
Again it's very much
a research project.
It's not just for kids actually,
it's for families too
because parents have
these things in
their house as well and
they also need to
understand them,
and we're trying to
understand how to create
experiences that parents and
kids can also do together.
So again, it's this graph
works like programming,
but you can see
a diversity of blocks.
There's Clarifying, their
Geebo, there's Alexa.
So, kids are being able to
create these custom IoT,
AI experiences
across a big palette
of these AI based technologies.
So, we allow them
to train models.
>> Because it's
going to learn what
those pictures are going to be.
>> Do you think computers
already know things
or people teach it?
>> People.
>> What you just did was just
teach a computer how
to do something?
>> You got a computer?
>> Yeah.
>> Sometimes
a computer teaches me.
>> It's like mind blown.
>> I'm trying to make
a computer recognize colours.
>> So, he's ten.
>> I'm labeling them as colours.
So, I [inaudible] here take
a picture and label it as green.
So, the computer can
recognize green and.
>> So, they're able to explain
how their training
these models and
that's important too, right?
>> Here's what you were saying
and I already asked it.
>> You have to say what text
is bad and what text
is happy or made
back-ended and over time,
it would be able to
recognize it without
you- Bad dog, good dog.
>> So, again through
the process of building
these projects,
kids are talking about
how the systems work,
how they need to change
the training set,
why the model's not right yet,
they're able to work
collaboratively,
they're able to
articulate their ideas,
they're able to think
creatively and systematically.
So, basically they're
learning a whole bunch of
21st century learning skills
as well which I think
is really critical.
So, we have an opportunity.
So, last week I think
was the week that
the Computer Science Teaching
Association partnered with
triple AI around AI education
and there's been a
very grassroots that
teachers movements to bring
computer science
education into k-12.
I think with that there's
an opportunity to
bring AI education into k-12.
And to really create
the curriculum and
exercises from the ground
up that's very hands on,
collaborative,
getting children to tinker
with the stuff to think
about this stuff and to build
a 21st century skills that we all
want and want our kids to have.
So, they have access to
these opportunities,
this incredible opportunities
in this time that we live in.
I think this is critical because
if we want truly humanistic AI,
we need to empower
a much greater diversity of
people to create
these technologies,
because it's people
from different walks of
life that have the empathy and
the appreciation of
the challenges and
the opportunities that mattered
to them in their communities.
So, whether it's creating
relational AIs that are
supportive of people in this
personalize empathetic
other or whether it's
these educational
initiatives that
empower a much broader diversity
of people to create with AIs,
kids as well as adults and
I would argue even seniors.
I think this is how
we're going to get
to AI that can truly
benefit everyone and
not just the few.
Alright, so I'm
going to end there.
Thank you very much. Do you
want to do question?
>> Yeah.
>> Questions.
>> When you're working
on your prior work
on Allies and personalization,
were the older adults,
I don't know what to
use, lonely or they're
alone in the community.
>> On the assisted living video?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So that was.
>> I'm wondering if that
play a role into being
more to technology as
opposed to the professionals
and like that.
>> Yeah.
So, I think what I mean
again I think what you're
seeing from the in-home
one month study in
general was I think the lesson to
me is older adults and seniors,
they do understand that
technology can help
them and empower
them but it needs
to be designed in
the right way so
they're open to it.
But, there's a lot of stuff
that are designed for them
that isn't necessarily
stuff they want to use.
So I think that was clear in
the assisted living facility
where actually the thing that was
compelling was it
was a practitioner
and facility who had
the intuition that
this technology could enhance
the way residents would
engage with one another.
So it was not replaced and
they made the point in
the story this was not about
replacing the practitioners,
it was really about saying if we
introduce this other kind
of technology,
can we spur a richer community
collaborative connection
among the residents so that was
the hypothesis in that study
is continuing to go on.
I don't think it's
because they're lonely,
I think it's because they see
technology as something
that can really help them,
it just needs to be designed
in the right way. Out there.
>> There's a recent case
where kids were
mistreating Alexa
and I think they
added in the new word
please Alexa.
Is there anything
about this approach
that might discourage
or make kids want to treat
the agent more respectfully.
>> Well, so, I think again,
we're in this very intriguing
time and especially with
these social robots
where children are
engaging them more
like an other versus
a device and what we
see is because of
that children like
I'll give an example,
so we did a study.
Last year and we just
did a longitudinal study
we're finishing up now looking
at children learn all kinds
of things from others.
There's kind of
this more curricular step.
There's also things like
attitudes like a growth mindset,
fixed mindset versus
growth mindsets
and children require
mindset based on
how adults often or
teachers praise them
and speak to them.
So, parents and teachers
reinforce that, "Oh,
you're so smart."
Then the concern is
what happens when
things get hard do
they seem like,
"Oh, I'm just not
good enough anymore."
Or if they praise effort
and that's how you learn
that's the growth mindset, right?
So, we designed
a puzzle-solving game
where we had children play
the game with either a,
we call it a neutral
mindset robot
because we thought a fixed
mindset would be unethical.
A neutral mindset
robot that would
just make factual comments about
the state of the gameplay
versus a growth mindset robot.
What we found was
that the children who
interacted with
a growth mindset robot,
self-identified greater
in the post testing
of having a growth mindset.
On the intentional parts of
the task where we
challenge kids and
actually made them fail,
they tried harder and they
demonstrated more grit.
So, and even in
that video I showed
you where the robot
says I believe in you
when she got it wrong
and you heard her
say back to the robot
I believe in you.
We see the social
modeling phenomenon
again and again and
again and again.
I would say at this point,
I think it's quite robust.
So and we're starting
to explore that
phenomenon and empathy,
can you actually have social
robots engage children with
a known issue with
bullying and to
have them become more empathetic.
So that's just to
say that engaging
their social emotional
processings and
behaving so I think this is
a technology that
clearly can do it.
It can be applied I think
to really help kids,
but then it needs to be done in
a really ethical responsible way
because clearly,
children are engaging
those parts of
their brain when
they're engaging with
this technology and I
think it's not just kids,
it's people of all ages.
So, yes I think
it's important that
these technologies
model the kind of
behavior that you want
because I think it
actually helps
reinforce the behavior
we want to see each other.
So I think there's an
opportunity there.
>> So, I'm thinking
about the transaction as
a social robot
comparisons, right?
Even in conversation systems
like chit chat systems.
I think it's very
hard to pin down
good reward functions that
reinforcement learners
can actually use.
So in the two examples that
you pointed out I'm curious
like how robust do you
think that reward functions
better how good-?
>> Yeah, I mean I think I
mean it's early days, right?
So I can say that what
we are doing is we
are those inputs are
going into the reinforcement
learning algorithm,
it's something is
trying to optimize.
So we're looking at
effective computing inputs
the biometrics for engagement,
we're looking at
their responsiveness
to the robots dialogic questions,
we're looking at whether they
get things right or wrong,
we're looking at
their language samples.
So we're trying to both
use reinforcement
learning to kind of
simultaneously maximize
engagement as well as
these learning outcomes
and we're seeing promise.
I think these are early days I
think that the point of showing
the slides is this
hasn't been done for kids this
young first of all, right?
I mean and building
a technology that
addresses these social,
emotional, nonverbal
things hasn't
been done for kids
like this, right?
So the fact that you
couldn't even show boost on
both the dimensions is
noteworthy and important is
just to say there's probably
a pony in there, right?
A lot more work needs to be done.
I think that's that's
kind of the state of
the field right now.
It's like we're starting to
see a different way of engaging
the human mind and behavior
that is actually I think
quite profound, right?
This is no longer
about naturalness.
These are deep social
processes that
this technology is able
to tap into, right?
So this is not shallow,
this is actually quite deep
and we need to understand it
and we need to think about
how can we leverage to
benefit people and we need to
be able to create best practices.
So it's not used to
obviously try to make people
do something that's to benefit
a third-party and not
the person themselves, right?
So it's just to say, we live in
an interesting times
but we are seeing
a very provocative psychology
happening here.
Again, it runs deep and I think
the more we do this work,
we're discovering how
deep it actually goes.
>> A lot of the agents have
this novelty effect like
that the kids see it,
they get super excited,
and it is hard to
make it permanent
like build this longer-term
friendship with them.
What are your thoughts about
this continued engagement?
How you can actually form
bonds and go beyond the novelty?
>> Absolutely, so I mean I think
you can see in a number
of these studies they're
longitudinal so
they're going well
beyond the kind of
novelty effect.
I actually think in
our field we need to
have a real deep systematic
investigation of what
we mean by the novelty
effect because
when I was first
a graduate student,
it was like a five-minute
encounter before
you started the task was enough
to address the novelty effect.
Now, it's like two weeks and you
haven't addressed
the novelty effect,
so we just need to be
much more rigorous and
what we mean when we
say the novelty effect.
That said, when you're
interacting with the system over
three months or a month every day
in the home you passed
the novelty effect.
So, it's a combination of things.
I do think there is
definitely you need
enough freshness
in the activities
or it's like no matter how
compelling Angry Birds is
it's going to get boring,
so you need enough variability
and freshness of
the activities to sustain
any sort of encounter.
I think these relational things
are also really important.
So, the fact that the robot
whether it's Jibo or Tega are
actually doing these
social grooming functions.
Greeting you in the morning,
asking you how your day was,
remembering that,
personalizing that to you,
commenting on did you have
another good night's sleep or
I'm sorry I hope you sleep
better tomorrow night,
did you sleep better tonight.
I mean these things
matter and I guess that's
what we're finding is
the personalization
combined I think with the,
again the supportive empathetic
other actually matters to people.
So, I think it's a combination of
those things and there's
other things as well.
But, we're at the very beginning
of understanding how you design
for sustained relationship and
you're starting to see
mechanisms were exploring here.
It's hard to do this work,
it's hard to deploy
these systems these robot
systems in people's homes for
a long period of time
to collect the data,
it's just hard, it's
logistically hard and expensive
to do but it's important work
that needs to be done.
So, it's just to say
there's a lot of
opportunity here I think
and very poignant.
But just like
interpersonal interaction,
I think there's
a whole set of processes
that are at play to build
that sustained sense
of not only just engagement,
but that kind of relationship
that you feel like you're
actually working with the other,
or for sustained period
of time to reach
a goal of personal significance.
I think that's also part of it.
>> I thought your part
about the AITutor was
really, really interesting.
What are some of
the next steps that you see
applications for the AITutor
given the technology
that we have right now?
>> Yeah. So, I mean, obviously
computer tutors is a huge field.
I think it tends
to be applied more
towards older students
and seems to
be tentative quite
more towards like
math and physics and kind of
STEM, explicit STEM areas.
We were going after the younger,
early childhood learning
for a number of reasons.
One is just it's
a critical time to intervene.
As I talked about, it's
an underexplored area for
technological innovation.
Children at that age just
learn in a very different way.
They absolutely learn from
friendly, empathetic others.
That's how they're
wired to learn,
so you need to design
to support that.
I think there's a whole host
of things we need to
address around early
childhood learning,
around early math and literacy.
Even the fastest growing
demographic internet
public schools are
English language learners,
which is why we are going
out to recruit from
schools with high English
language learning populations.
Kids with special needs is
another huge area, right?
So, whether it's
attentional issues,
or ASD, or whatnot,
I think there's
huge opportunities
for again kind of giving
everyone the best
possible chance of
being successful by addressing
a diversity of learners.
That's where I think a lot of
high impact opportunity is.
On the flip side, I think you can
look at workforce retraining.
With all that kind of
concern about AI
replacing our jobs,
I think there's
a huge opportunity for AI
to actually train
us for new jobs.
So, I think that
could become a new,
another kind of huge
impact area for education.
There's a lot more
discussion around kind of
lifelong learning as well
and continuing education.
So, it's all important.
But for me, just after
looking at all of
the data and all the
unmet opportunity,
it's the early childhood stuff.
The fact that the die is being
cast for way too many children,
way too early in their
life. It's just not right.
So, I do think that's going
to be the biggest kind
of social justice area of
intervention for
education. You asked when?
>> Yeah, [inaudible].
At one point,
you were showing
how people perceive
the personalities
of Alexa and Jibo.
I'm wondering for Jibo,
how did that match
the intended design of
Jibo's personality or is there
anything that
surprised you there?
>> I think that's-
that did match I think
the kind of design stance
of how Jibo was designed.
I mean, he's designed to be
open and extroverted and to,
you know, convey and elicit
this emotive kind of
empathetic response.
We would like it if he was
perceived to be
more conscientious.
You know, [inaudible] technology
continues to improve
and evolve you know,
but- and he just doesn't,
he doesn't have
10 thousand skills chat.
So, there's some of
that at play as well.
But in terms of, you know,
I think again
the punchline for me,
especially that working
average of seeing the trends,
is to say that's where
the social robotics
is really showing
up because Alexa
has arguably more
offerings in all of
those categories
than a product like
Jibo that's only been
on the market
a few months and yet,
you see this different
in engagement.
That's the social robotics
coming through.
That's a different way that
the robot are showing up to
people in their lives that's
leading to that engagement.
I think this is
something the field
or even on the
consumer landscape,
any corporations
have yet to really
grasp is that this is
actually, this is different.
This kind of experience
is quite different.
And you know, it's appealing to
a diversity of users
that I think it's also
noteworthy, right?
So, I think the punchline
for me is also,
if younger adults
are are keying in on
utility that's just a matter
of time for social robots,
they're going to
have the skills too.
So, at some point,
that's going to be mood and then,
it really is about
these other aspects.
It is about this other
relational AI aspects.
And that technology to me
that says in the long run,
social robotics are going to
be the next thing, right?
Because you can't just always
be disembodied talking
speakers, right?
Clearly that's going
to be the glide path
and we're starting to see
it in this engagement data.
And again, it just gets down
to the way our brains work.
We evolve to want to connect and
relate to animate
entities in this way,
and you know, the more you
design to support that,
the richer the engagement, right?
So, I think it's not
surprising when you
think about it that way,
but I think the industry
has to kind of catch up.
I think right now,
our spoken language systems are
very much like playing chess.
It's like discrete turns,
but communication, human
communication is it's a dance.
It's not playing chess.
It's mutually regulated.
It's dynamic. It's fluid.
It's all of these things
and that's where
all these other things
like liking and trust and
affiliation come to play.
So.
>> Give another chance.
>> Okay.
>> I'm just, maybe this is
projecting way too
far in the future,
but I remember reading an article
where it was said that dogs
have been bred to
the point where they
prefer the company of humans
to the company of dogs.
And so, it's not that
far-stretched to think that
eventually the social robot
will be socially far
superior to other humans and
then humans may start
preferring the company of robots
to the company of humans,
and how far in the future
do we think that is?
>> Yeah.
>> We have already
observed, how this is?
>> Yeah, so I will say
this, people need people.
We need to feel that we
belong to our community.
We need to feel valued
by our community,
that our community
cares about us.
We can't flourish if we
don't have that and so,
I think these robots and
these intelligent technologies
are going to be,
a wonderful augmentation
of society,
but people still will
always need people.
And these technologies should be
designed to enhance
and support that.
>> I'm not sure I
get your premise.
I mean, it's certainly
not true for dogs.
>> Well, so- but I'm not
talking about the dog.
I'm talking about what
it is to be human.
Humans need humans.
I'm not saying dogs can't be
bred to prefer humans over dogs.
I'm saying the way human
beings are by our very nature,
we are profoundly
social species, right?
We've evolved to need.
You know, social pain
is now being
appreciated to be
real pain, right?
It's not just this kind
of stiff upper lip thing,
it's processed in
the same regions
of the brain. It's actual pain.
We're just, you know,
chronic loneliness is a series of
a health condition as smoking
and obesity and substance abuse.
It's like we're just
starting to really
appreciate the neuroscience,
of how deeply social we are.
So, people need people.
>> You're making the premise of
what you're saying is
based on the fact that we
will never have more empathy
for robot than for
human, is that correct?
>> I think that
human relationships
are complex and messy and
important and they make
life worth living. I do.
There's something about
the human-human relationship
that I don't think
you're going to be able
to replace with a machine.
I don't think you can't
create machines that
are going to help
benefit people in
profoundly important ways,
but I don't think
they're going to replace
what's important about
human connection to people.
And I'd be willing to say I think
the neuroscience is
going to show that.
>> [inaudible] question.
[inaudible] to define
social robotics as robots
with social skills?
>> So, I think like
all aspects of robots
you can probably
put a panel of experts on
social robotics and
probably give you
different definitions of
what a social robot is,
just like they're going
to give you definition,
different definitions
of what a robot is.
So, they absolutely
have social skills.
I would say it's
beyond that though.
They are engaging...it's how
they engage people, right?
They are engaging
these social thinking,
reasoning mechanisms of a person.
>> Would it be fair that
they operate in a way,
in a form of social engineering?
>> I don't know. I
don't understand.
Form of social engineering.
I mean, there...
>> Manipulation.
Through the simulation of
social or human
like social skills.
>> So I would say
that absolutely.
So, as they are designed,
the human mind engages
with them in a way
that we evolved to be,
and you can design
these systems to use
that to benefit people.
>> And I guess that
Patricia's comment was
in for as there's
the danger of
manipulating robusticity,
so the question is, there
was this video about
the, what was it,
the ledger about this ledger
that Google released so far.
Who is motivating
this social robots
to that we're going to have?
>> This is what's so
important to discuss.
Yeah. So, whether it's virtual
reality and people's [inaudible]
sensors being stimulated
like it's the real thing
or whether it's
advertising or cinema,
we're not strangers to artifacts
manipulating us, right?
We do this all the time
in many, many
different capacities.
Our games are advertised,
this is not
the new new thing it's
just to say that it can
happen here as well
and we need to understand it
and we need to have
dialogues around
best practices and how
it should be implied
to benefit people.
Because clearly,
the good news here
is that it can really
benefit people,
but you don't want
unintended consequences, right?
>> I love you're saying
this. Because this is
a very perhaps
subtle atomic bomb.
So you saying, let's have
children interact with
robots that are experts
in social engineering.
Go. So, having that
running without concern of
people like you
will be dangerous.
>> And I would say it's
like anytime you're
trying any form of
learning right.
Designing a serious game, right?
I mean, this is,
what this is is a different
dimension of designing
technologies that interface with
the human mind and
behavior, right?
That's what all of this is
essentially about right?
And is to say, just like too
much screen time right now
people are willing to
say that screens can
be addictive to kids, right?
It's to say eyes wide open with
any technology with
any age group,
I wouldn't say just kids,
with any age group.
Tremendous benefit as possible
but you got to keep
eyes wide open.
Absolutely. So, you wanted
to ask the question.
>> The charts, how
did you measure and
benchmark emphathy.
>> On?
>> There were like
multiple charts
and empathy was showing.
>> So, this was literally like
a personality test
that you would give to
people that people filled
out for the agent.
So, there was like
standard questions asked on
a personality test is what
this what that represented.
>> So, the people measured
empirically based on
their understanding-
>> So, people were
asked a question,
like here's a set of
questions how would
you rate the agent.
Just like if you are taking
a personality test for yourself,
fill it out for yourself,
they were doing
that for the agent.
Here's a set of questions,
how would you fill it out?
So that's what that
was generated from.
It's literally like a personality
test, but just applied.
People applied it to the agent.
>> Curious. Have
you noticed maybe
an analogy with
the uncanny valley
with social interactions
like if people kind of
recoiled like that's too
realistic or kind of a weird out.
>> Yeah so the uncanny valley
I think it's something
that people throw
that term out a lot.
Really what it means is the
more human-like
something becomes,
you go into this kind of
feels creepy kind of factor.
So I think for me
a more recent example is
human animated
characters in film.
At the time of
the first tin toy Pixar,
I don't know if you
remember the baby
in a concrete diaper.
Way in the valley,
way in the valley,
but then at some point Shrek,
whatever, clearly we could
tell that there
wasn't a real human,
but the aesthetic was
out of the valley right?
So something as abstract as
Geebo isn't really something
that's going to
fall in the valley,
because it's meant to be how
exactly human-like it looks,
it's kind of that conjecture
is really about.
But, I would say that when
you ask people creepy,
creepy can mean any number
of things to people,
it could mean creepy because
it seems so life-like,
to another person would make
it seem really cool right?
And then there's kind of creepy
like walking corpse creepy,
which is that's what
the uncanny valley
I think was really getting on.
>> One more, I just
have a quick question.
When do you think Geebo
will get arms and legs?
like we have all these Alexas
and things like speakers that are
stationary but when
are you suppose.
>> So, I would say you know when
people ask me what
a social robot is,
a social robot is not
something that only sits
on your countertop.
I happened to build those systems
because I want to
focus on the social.
But I would argue Baxter
is a social robot,
because it was designed to
work collaboratively with
the person and it's
got the screen
with the eyes and the attention.
It's a social
manufacturing robot,
so you know Toyota research,
other people are going to create
mobile manipulator social robots
because they have to live with
people and it's that social
interpersonal competence
that's going to be critical for
fitting into people's lives
and them wanting to have it
around and for actually being
collaborative and helpful.
So, I just think it's all,
it's all going to happen.
Okay can you [inaudible].
>> I thought it was
interesting that
the interaction
was sort of better
when the robot switched from
being expert to novice,
because I think
a lot of us do like
robot as a student or
robot as a teacher,
but sort of doing.
But how did you decide what
exactly an expert and
novice meant because,
I think the way we interact
with each other there's
like a graded scale of
how we're an expert
and how we're novice.
>> Yeah. So, there were
specifically different
behaviors that
the robot would do
in either role.
So, in novice role,
the robot may ask a question and
the reason why it's really
asking the question
it's because it wants
the child to articulate,
because that's going
to help them learn,
but it's playing the
role of the novice.
Or in the novice role the
robot would intentionally make
a mistake and ask
the child why do you
think that was wrong.
So those are examples
of novice behaviors.
Expert behaviors would be things
like giving the definition of
the word or giving the
child a hint, right?
So in this particular
implementation,
there were just different
kinds of behaviors the robot
would do in one
role or the other.
We use reinforcement
learning plus
some adaptation to switch
the roles dynamically
based on how the child
was doing both from
a kind of affective
computing standpoint as
well as their actual performance
in the game, right?
So the robot was always
making decisions based on
how do I best support
this child in
this moment even as it
was kind of taking
this different kind of role.
But what we definitely
saw anecdotally
was children kind of,
they're kind of they came a
little more of
a lean back experience
when the robot's behavior
was predictable
and it always kind of took
one role or the other,
whereas when it was mixing it up,
they noticed more, and
what we also found,
again the social modeling thing,
is the more the robot talks
about its own process,
the more children talk out
loud about their process.
So, we see the social modeling
happening again and again in
so many different constructs
and in this case
it's obviously done in
a way to promote
the children's learning,
because the more
they articulate and
reflect and verbalize the
more likely they are
to actually learn
these things, right? So.
>> In each role is the robot
learning what just- say,
because I can imagine like
in the future and it has
some sort of part of behavior.
>> So it's not learning on
the fly how to generate,
there's a set of kinds of
parameterized utterances
it's going to say,
so it's kind of more
templatized of these form.
In the future, yeah,
you can imagine having that
be much more flexible.
But in the case of
this particular work it was
more templated kinds
of responses.
Okay. Good?
>> Thank you again Cynthia.
>> Great. Thank you